What's going on?
Everybody [welcome] to another python series this series is going to be concerning my sequel with python
so if you're only after simple storage and retrieval
And you want just the most basic solution for that yet. You still want to use an sql database
then you might be interested more so in my sqlite series so sqlite as its name suggests is a
Lightweight Sql solution that is really easily used with python and so I will put the links of those three videos in the [description]
Basically the first one setting up the database second one is storing Data and the third one is retrieving Data now
Historically I've avoided doing a full my sequel tutorial
[mostly] because like windows users are going to tend to have issues installing and setting up an sql server to run on their computer and
It just it just would have been a mess right so you got a like set it up and open up the right ports
It's in the correct information to the ninth ward of the interplanetary Xenon space [cake] Victor Charlie Alpha
And you know what at that point?
You know people just kind of throw in the towel, so we wouldn't really get very far
Probably have really bad retention because it's just kind of tough
So I
did just recently show you guys that python anywhere website which is here and
I
Thought you know what this would be a good place to do sql plus python. So anybody that doesn't want to have to deal with
installing my sequel or
My sequel post python rather so anybody there was one I deal with you know installing and setting up a my sequel server
Maybe run their computer if they don't already have like a shared hosting
Plan somewhere or even VPS and whatnot
That [they] could still follow along so even noobs because most of my tutorials
I try to make them to the point where if you're brand new you can still follow along
so really this just makes the perfect solution because
everyone in it will be able to follow along identically with me if they want to and
Everyone is on the same platform. So that makes it just super easy
So setting up an account on here is real quick and easy
if you don't have an account already
You probably [rive] at a page like this. It's completely free to make an account. You. Just don't get a lot of processing
[but] [we'll] structure the tutorial so you won't exceed that processing anyways
[so] you can make an account just click here, and it's very sincere, [and] it's a little statement here
You can create a beginner account and literally you fill this out hit this register
You're ready to go, so I'm going to go ahead and log in now to my account
[which] just so happens to be beginner account?
So [I'll] log [into] that apparently that was
Dashboard I don't know why it sent me back to that page anyway
So when you log in you should see something like this, and it just so happens that they've actually already got
my sequel installed and
ready to go if you
decided to not follow my
My advice and just follow us here you can run a sudo apt-get install my sequel - server sudo apt-get install
Python - my sequel DB then do a my seat or go into your you know my sequel?
Like with bash my sequel - you root - p get it. Just whatever it takes for you to get into that basically my sequel
Line here, well, we can't I can't show you just yet, but I'll show you guys in [a] second
And then you just you know write create Database test DB
Or whatever you want to make and you're the name of your database, and then you'll be able to follow along with us
[and] that should be really it if you want to cheat so anyways with that
I'm gonna let that you guys that want to blaze your own path will continue blazing your own path
[so] anyway if now that you've got an account whenever you come here
what we want to do is yeah, we want to make a database here, so
and then also keep this in mind whenever you're
Connecting to a database like say you did have a local database a lot of times you can just say
[Localhost] is where you want to connect
As long as the files are [on] the same server, but you can't do that here
[so] this will take the place of Localhost
And then your username is the same username you're using and then database password suggested that you don't use the same password
account name
Because of right here, it's going to any any like text or any python applications
You write that database password is going to be visible invisible?
So with that I'm going to go ahead and make [my] password um
cookies
Since y'all are going to see it anyways, so set database password awesome
So now we've got
The first database here, and you can see the name of the database as always you get set [up] with a default database
Or a database called default but every database you ever make like if you make another database like I'll make a database called tutorial
And you create that database
You'll see that it always starts with beginner account [dollar] son, and then the name [of] that database
So that's that now you've got the database setup announced
Learn to kind of communicate with it. So eventually yeah, you want to communicate with it via a python script
But also you want to know how to communicate with it by hand basically so you can later communicate, Via
Ssh, and then later communicate via. Ssh by your program
So it does become useful to be able to do this in plus if you want to run especially when it comes to creating tables
That sometimes, it's just quicker by hand to make [it] by hand
then to code a program that makes the table if
It's a new thing anyways if you're going to be making a lot of new tables
And you might as well make a program to do it, but anyway
and then also when it comes to like deleting or getting rid of maybe corrupt data you usually do that by hand, so
Anyway, um it's good to know how to do it. So what we're going to do is pop over to consoles now
They're nice, and they give us a my sequel console, so you can just click on this and you start
already in the my sequel console as soon as it loads and
So yeah, so you're ready to give my sequel queries
But not everybody is going to have it that way and if you ever move on past [maybe] hosting here you have another hosting
Provider you pry are going to get that you're just gonna have a bash line when you connect by ssh
It's going to look more like this so how you get to that my sequel first of all you better
have my sequel installed and a database and everything but
here what you're going to do is call my [C] cool and then
[we're] going to - you and then you put in your [username] in my case. It's beginner I
Was a beginner user being in our account already forgot. Let me go, okay. Look I just made it. It's beginner at count
So it gets right good job. We get our account and then - h and
So user is just your [username] right and then - h will [be]
Where you're connecting so a lot of times it would be localhost, but in our case. We can't do that
so it's my sequel dot server and
@p and now you're going to need to put in the password. This is the password
Your database password right so in my case. It was cookies. Whatever yours is can be whatever. I highly suggest cookies. It's a great password
I'm just kidding. I don't anyway
[so] now we're in the database so the first thing that you'll be able to do and the only thing that we can do so
Far since pretty much all we have is a database is run a command called show databases
Don't forget your semicolons otherwise. It's going to do this to you, and you're going to like I forgot my semicolon
Anyway, so now what it's going to do is is print out. It's a best attempt at a gui and it prints out
You know we've got information
Information schema, then we've got the default table or I mean a default database not a table
And then we've got the one that we made
Now it's not really necessary. You don't have to do your commands [in] all caps, but all generally especially in code
It makes it really helpful to anybody reading it to know
What's like a table name, and what's an actual sequel command?
So you've got all kinds of stuff like oops
[I] thought I hit the caps select and insert and delete and all this kind of stuff
[an] update not that update so you put in all caps
But you don't have to but [just] helps for your purposes and debugging and also reading your own old scripts
maybe and then also if you're collaborating with people
It's just nice another useful query to have it. You can run it pretty much whenever is show
Process list and what this is going to do is show you all the processes that are occurring right now
[and] so if you ever have like a process that you find yourself with my sequel is use
Up a hundred percent of your cPU and you want to know what the heck is going on?
You can do this and see what kind of processes are still running and then you can shut them down
[by] their little Id right here, so you can kill the process
I'll probably show you guys that later
But anyway, just that's where you can start whenever if you if you do find yourself at [100%] you don't know why?
so
Anyway, those are the basic topics now in the next video. I'm going to be talking about setting up a new table, [Via]
you know the same rule command line here [and]
Then a little bit of inserting data into those tables, and then probably in the next video after that
Manipulating that data a little bit just and then also just some pro tips right. I'm not a pro
But these are other people's pro tips so anyway
Stay tuned for those videos as always. Thanks for watching thanks [for] the support in the subscriptions and until next time